estos baños públicos se han convertido
en un lugar de conmemoración el pasado
14 de septiembre una empleada del metro
murió tras haber sido apuñalada aquí
este crimen conmocionó al país Cada día
los habitantes de la ciudad dejan flores
y mensajes de apoyo como esta estudiante
Universitaria
lo que me da mucha rabia es que el
gobierno insista en que no se trató de
un feminicidio sino del acto de un
individuo
que solo fue un incidente desafortunado
según la ministra de igualdad de género
no es un crimen misógino una declaración
que ha desatado fuertes críticas desde
hace tres años el sospechoso la acosaba
con mensajes visitas incesantes y la
amenazaba supuestamente por amor incluso
instaló una pequeña cámara en los baños
del metro para poder filmarla sin que
ella lo supiera un fenómeno de voyerismo
digital conocido como molca frecuente en
el país
siempre estoy un poco intranquila cuando
veo pequeños huecos en las paredes de
los baños me pregunto eso será una
cámara muchas jóvenes piensan igual que
yo tengo una amiga que solo utiliza los
baños que ha revisado a fondo
afuera de la estación
se une a un grupo de feministas varias
semanas después del crimen las
activistas siguen expresando su
indignación
el foco de la manifestación es el
gobierno conservador que no estaría
haciendo lo suficiente para proteger a
las mujeres
quiere eliminar el Ministerio de
igualdad de género Aunque ahora los
casos se estén multiplicando en 2016
otro asesinato en el metro incendió al
país hace un año una nueva ley convirtió
el acoso en un delito sancionable con
tres años de prisión cuando antes la
pena máxima era una multa de 80 dólares
[Música]
desde entonces la cantidad de casos
reportados sea multiplicado por 6 pero
las activistas recuerdan que en este
tipo de situaciones suele haber muy
pocas denuncias esta víctima no tuvo las
ganas ni el valor para acudir a las
autoridades hace un año un encuentro
inicialmente banal con un hombre se
convirtió en una pesadilla casi todos
los días la llamaba e iba a ver a su
lugar de trabajo una panadería similar a
esta
dije que dejara de venir pero seguía
pasando por mi trabajo
me llamaba con frecuencia no hacía caso
a lo que yo le decía no sabía qué más
hacer
a veces le pedía a su hermano que
cerrara la panadería en su lugar su
madre tuvo que usar las cámaras de
seguridad para vigilarla como muchas
otras víctimas ella no pensaba que la
policía pudiese protegerla hace dos
meses su acosador dejó de aparecer
lo que más me asustaba era que si yo
presentaba una denuncia él se enterara
me habría dado miedo su reacción
realmente hay que pensar dos veces antes
de hacerlo
todavía tengo miedo de que vuelva a
aparecer sin avisar sigue Sabiendo donde
trabajo
según las activistas el principal
problema de la ley actual es que el
acoso no puede ser sancionado sin el
consentimiento expreso de la víctima
esto incita a que los sospechosos acosen
aún más a sus víctimas para que retiren
la denuncia se emiten pocas órdenes de
alejamiento y no siempre son eficaces
sin embargo esta directora de Un refugio
para mujeres piensa que un nuevo cambio
de ley no Debería ser la prioridad se
podría hacer mucho más si las leyes
existentes se aplicaran de manera
correcta la policía y los fiscales
deberían desarrollar su conocimiento y
su sensibilidad sobre este tema del
acoso
antes en nuestro país las personas
pensaban que seguir a una mujer por la
calle
o tener un comportamiento obsesivo era
simplemente una manera de expresar un
sentimiento romántico
y todavía hay mucha gente que comparte
esta idea
tan solo alrededor del 1% de los casos
de acoso reportados terminan con una
detención el gobierno ha prometido
decretar penas más severas pero las
activistas temen que las amenazas sin
educación no permitan que haya un
verdadero cambio en las mentalidades